hey I'm Damon labyrinths from wired and
this is the Tesla Model S this is
actually the upgraded model s but not
upgrade the way you think it looks the
same it's more or less the same vehicle
we tested a few months ago but Tesla
just pushed out a pretty major software
update that includes that new features
for the navigations new audio features
telephone features that kind of thing
also when you approach the car the door
handles pop out automatically it's kind
of cool one feature we like a lot is
actually you hold down the button to
enter an oyster and then let go when
you're done talking play DJ Shadow radio
and it'll start streaming directly
through slacker something of a slacker
you can do a search for point of
interest or addresses navigate to 111
minna street san francisco
they've got a new projected range graph
that actually have toggles between
average and instance the control knob on
the right-hand side of the steering
connection be configured for a couple
different things now including can
actually control the sunroof just by
pressing it once you can customize this
for the climate controls the event speed
that kind of thing you can actually
access the release notes directly from
the home screen here